Chris Webber joining us from Houston how
are you C Webb hey great how do you
doing what was that like having a front
row seat next to Marv watching the
greatest comeback in the history of the
NBA playoffs Chris you know I was
telling Marvin our production meeting
this morning that I was so into the game
that this is weird that I didn't even
think that that was a comeback happening
because in the start of third quarter
going to stay with nine for nine and so
you know they play well in the third
quarter and so I'm thinking yeah this is
gonna be tough you just got to play hard
and win the next quarter and just so you
can go watch film and it was one of the
most remarkable things that I've ever
seen and what probably is the most
remarkable is those guys actually
believed that they could come back if
they would have lost being the Clippers
they would have been so disappointed and
my whole thing was you're playing the
champs at home you're down 31 there's no
way in hell you could come back and so
that's the great thing about sports man
it was awesome and sitting there next to
the voice
isn't there's no better way to watch
that game well you know how I feel about
him who you and I have had conversations
about that how real this how real is
this though obviously boogy Cousins is
out for the rest of this series he could
be out for the rest of the postseason
should the Warriors advance but how
realistic is it for the Clippers to win
three out of the remaining five games
here
well they've shown me that anything's
possible I tell you that but I you know
I think they're gonna not I don't think
that they should use that game as the
template of how to play and get down
early I think I think it's possible for
them to win but more so if I'm Houston
moreso or farm guys that are coming next
I'm happy about this year's beat there's
no way you can play the Clippers and
come out better then you started the
series they're gonna be worse for the
wear and so I don't know if they really
have a chance but but you never know but
they're going to have an impact on the
next series I feel even if even if
Golden State goes on to win the
championship they're going to feel the
effects in any series because of playing
this clipper team they're not you can't
be better'n without boogie cousins I'm
not really I feel bad for him
but for the team
the years that they play well Bogut was
their center and it was because he
facilitated and he kept the movement
going on the offensive in so offensively
I don't think they're gonna miss
anything but but as a team they really
wanted to win one floor boogie and so I
I don't know what that'll take away from
and Shinobu motivation for him but I
doubt it cuz another chance and they're
just trying to get three in a row right
now your colleague Chris in Berkeley
told Dan Patrick this morning he thinks
the Blazers are going to win the West do
you think the West is open for business
here III don't know you know anytime you
have going to state I can't say that the
West is open and Houston by the way is
is a pretty good team and if they
wouldn't miss 27 three-pointers in Game
seven last year David have gone to the
championship so 27 in a row I don't
think necessarily the West is that wide
open but that's why I love Chuck he sees
other things and any any let you know
about them but for me my money still
with it's going to state and or Houston
because because just they have so much
firepower they can play fast they can
play slow and they have players that you
know Aeterna sending players so I still
think it's going to stay that useful
well one of the reason why I bring it up
is not only because Charles you know
obviously knows what what what's what
but you and Charles you and Charles
shared the belief before the season that
the Lakers weren't even close to a
playoff team and you were the only guys
saying something like that and lo and
behold Lakers didn't even come close I'm
wondering what what you think of the
Lakers maneuvers over the last couple of
weeks from magic to letting letting Luke
go basically walk to Sacramento and I'm
wondering what you think about the next
few weeks here for Los Angeles Chris
yeah well first of all John Tavares for
you know pouncing on that situation
right away and making sure that you know
he was the benefactors getting a really
good coach because Luke is a really good
color I just think about this when you
look at the young kid out there in New
York the point guard and he's playing so
well you look at Julius Randle another
kid out there and New Orleans and you
look at Kuzma ball
and their young starters in Ingram if
you would have just kept that team they
would be the best young team in the NBA
now they may make the playoffs they may
not but they would have been really good
I mean some great draft picks were were
some great drafts and some great players
were picked in the draft by the Lakers
and so to have to start over I know was
really tough but then again if you get
LeBron you're already ahead of the game
I don't know very honestly if they can
make the playoffs next year of course we
have to see what team they have but if
you do not get shooters around LeBron if
you don't get players that can play his
style of play the one of the greatest
players to ever touch a basketball then
it really doesn't matter that you have
them on the floor because you're not
letting him be his best and I'd really
thought LeBron played a great had a
great season this year but it doesn't
matter how great he is if he drives to
the hole draws the defense he kicks it
out to a guy who can't score so I'm
wondering it seems like allow disarray
the Lakers aren't the landing spot that
you know maybe the media or people that
live in LA think that they are it's not
that that lure it's not oh my god I want
to go there a lot of guys live there in
the offseason and enjoy LA and not you
know have to play for the Lakers I think
that the Clippers are going to get two
free agents two super free agents in the
all-star I mean in the offseason and I
think that Clippers are the new
destination in LA I think the Clippers
are where players want to play and where
they see themselves in the future and so
if I'm the Lakers I you know you really
have to attack free agency think about
this they could've got Bradley bill
before the all-star break and if you to
have Bradley bill now with LeBron you
only have to worry about one free agent
you know so I really don't I don't know
what's going on you know the way the
magic quit so abruptly kind of you know
worried me a little bit when you talked
about backbiting and all that inside so
it's just isn't the way you would love
to see the great Lakers organization be
and I'm just like every other fan like
one pins-and-needles can't wait to see
what they do over the offseason because
um they put themselves in a pretty tough
situation and the expectations of myself
and fans around the country are hey you
got to get to a championship so looking
forward to seeing how alpha Lincoln and
Jenny buss and everybody gets to that
gets to that outcome well Chris you are
around Durant over the last couple of
days and Golden State and the sense is
is that Durant's already made his
decision Chris Haines of ESPN and the
undefeated says that that's not the case
I'm wondering what you think do you
think Durant has made his decision and
that he's out and if so is it possible
his destination is Los Angeles I mean
what what sense did you get right there
I would I would bet money he's not going
to the Lakers that's just me but then
again who knows I would have bet money
that he wouldn't have left of 3-1 and I
would've bet that he had to go back and
beat Golden State so I really don't know
his mentality I don't claim to know it
like that but I don't I don't I could
definitely see him leaving but again I
think that a lot of reporters a lot of
people want LA to do well and so they
slide the needle to that side and say
hey I think he's going there we're not
when basketball players and agents I
don't believe that they think the same
as that I don't say it's a done deal
with Durant leaving but I don't think
New York is I don't think New York is
totally out of the question I mean the
thing about so this year we have the
most free agents we've ever had in the
NBA or almost 40% mmm but the thing is
crazy about the free agents that we have
usually you have free agents that
haven't won a championship so you can go
guys like myself or maybe patch inland
or I don't know Chuck or getting trade
it but the difference is this is you
have guys that have won championships so
the incentive isn't the same Kawhi
Leonard doesn't have to go to a team to
win a championship right away he can
have the patient to say hey we can build
like you can have a different pitch for
him let's say who else in the freezer
Kyrie he has a championship Durant he
has a championship there so I could see
guys going to a place say like New York
that hasn't won in a while because they
want to bring one championship to a city
and they've already you know had their
individual time to win and they can go
through the process so I think that this
is a season unlike any other an
offseason going to be on all season like
any other and that's why it's going to
be fun to see what guys get together and
go places but again I la is the Lakers
are are not sexy they're like they're
not a place people want to go to just
because magic Kareem and coke
plate there is it's not that's not the
perception the narrative has changed and
I know a lot of people don't want to
accept it especially Lakers fans but
that's kind of the reality and but it
can change at any moment all you got to
do is prove one great player and you're
right back to dominance just one more
second on this before we turn to the
east here and then the series that's
right there in front of you you're
calling tonight on TNT with the Rockets
and jazz Chris Webber here on the Rich
Eisen show so just to just again explain
to me the mentality that that someone of
Durant's caliber and with a team that
he's on right now clearly the class of
the NBA even even with everything else
that we're talking about that can they
be beaten sure one night for sure over a
span of seven games possibly I get it
but I mean what a situation from coach
ownership to new arena what was the
mentality of him basically saying I need
to do something on my own
what-what-what-what goes between the
temples to make it a a high-caliber
terrific basketball player think in that
manner you know I'm really not sure it
could be you know personal motivation
the fact that so many fans were down on
him for jumping to that team that maybe
he wants to prove that he can do it on
his own maybe it's the chemistry in the
locker room maybe it's the chemistry
unlock them as well maybe it's getting
to a market like New York or someone
else and and now being ready and saying
hey I've learned how to win on this
level and I've learned how to win on
this level and now I can show someone
else how to do it yeah it does seem like
the perfect situation there and going to
state but I've said before I don't think
going to state can keep her I mean I
don't think Girma state can keep curry
Thompson green and Durant I just think
that's impossible so even if he does
come back somebody has to leave and they
won't have the same team Golden State is
gonna don't estate you know that the
league is gonna be open in the next two
to three years because Golden State is
not going to be same team and so maybe
he sees that in the future maybe he
wants to play with some of his friends
maybe he wants to live in a different
place you know it definitely seems like
he has the best situation possible and
why would you want to leave but the new
generation of guys
they think a little bit differently and
again he has Championships and so now
what is the next step about is it about
leading your team to championship is it
about being the MVP of the league is it
about getting a little more personal
accolades and things like that I'm not
sure what that motivation is but it does
seem like he would be in the perfect
situation if he just decided to stay all
right a couple more minutes left here
with Chris Weber who is your MVP
Yanis or the guy you're seeing tonight
in Harden wow man that's so tough but I
definitely go I definitely go with
Harden it is to me it's uh it's very
close and I love what Yanis has done but
but to me harden has been one of the
best players if not the best player in
the last four years in the NBA I know
people don't like the style of play but
get over it it's what you can do and not
too many other players can do that
that's the way they're running if you
think about all the dribbling and him
staying at the top of the key and if we
talk to Barkley about this many times I
get that is that Barkley and myself
wouldn't want to play in that system but
we're not in those systems and they
don't have players that can do a part we
did and if you can imagine posting up
Shaq Kobe does the ball in the shot the
double-team come Shaq throws him out to
Kobe Kobe waits for the double-team and
leaves he throws it back in the shack
and Shaq goes to work Shaq has touched
the ball the only one and Kobe has
touched the ball on this play and it
stays on one side of the court and
everybody else Fisher Fox all those guys
you stink on one side and don't move
well harden he has the ball to top urkki
he's dribbling he passed it to the
corner he gets it back at the top he
waits he dribbles and then he attacks
and goes to work it's just a new way to
post up for the top is not beautiful
it's not the way maybe that most of us
think basketball was meant to be played
but until somebody besides going to
state can stop it in a seven-game series
I think it's brilliant for them to play
the way they play and it's outside of
the comfort zones of many so I don't
think any team has embraced our own
personality throughout maybe the history
of basketball because this is such a
this is so different from what we're
doing I mean the fact that this team
wants to shoot 60 3s in a game are you
kidding me so they've really embraced
who they are and hard and you can't stop
them offensively we haven't seen
anything like this
think there's four players to average
over 36 points in a season wilt Jordan I
forgot who the other one was and Harden
and so what we've seen from offensively
the fact that his team down the stretch
I mean like the last 25 games they or
the last 33 games they've gone last 32
games about twenty five and seven and
hardens just a man and so I love what
I'm the Coupole has done I think he's
next but for me I just I don't know you
know without Chris Paul just just how
great this team is played with Harden is
just just incredible to see him tonight
against Utah so I'm assuming you think
this is the rocket series obviously to
to advance and there are they the best
team you think to take Golden State out
then Chris I'm not sure you know you
still got San Antonio who even though
they lost the lost of 19.8 last night
it's amazing let's remember they were up
when Kauai hurt his ankle I know those
three years ago they were up on the
Warriors by 20 in the first game it's a
different animal over there so I still
say you have to worry about San Antonio
but yeah I think Houston this they've
been if all things are fair and correct
they've been sitting on a game seven
pain and hurt and loss for almost a year
now and I think that should account for
something as far as in their attention
to detail their preparation and and how
hard they're going to play press the
great stuff as always great chat always
loved catching up with you let's do it
again real soon have a great cast
I can't wait to the NFL Draft as well so
I could check the show out there you
know I'm getting ready for that -
definitely can appreciate that hoody do
you have a sense of what you want the
Lions to do and all Chris or I know that
you're focused on me no no I don't want
to do I'm just you know obviously
they're they're in the best player
available part of the first round the
best play available category because you
aren't we lost so much last year yeah I
don't know I do believe this it is not
our quarterbacks fault and we need help
on the defensive end so I um you know
what I usually have all the answers for
the Lions I'm not giving up I'm just
like I'm just like hey guys you show me
I can't even be a backseat quarterback
to people I'm
lost and I just want us to win to get to
the playoffs what whatever it takes
whatever it takes because my only other
team is the Cleveland Browns and I
started them being a fan of them the
year that Barry retired I think it was
99 and then that same year Barry retired
Cleveland was reinstated like I've had
two terrible teams for a long time and
so Cleveland's going to give me a little
of it maybe you know the front office
will see what they've done and say hey
we know we want one playoff game and
most of our fans like tablets let's go
for it let's go for it this year so
hopefully uh I believe we need to put
more pressures on the families that hone
these teams so oh I'm getting no no
Chris I had no idea you were a Browns
guy like that I mean I love Baker
Mayfield man he is a total difference
maker period end of story
yes he is you know and I believe that
with obj and the friendship of him and
the receivers and and I really believe
all that matters and you have guys that
have to play for something you have guys
that everybody's doubting you and you
have a city that everybody doubts and
leaves out to dry it makes fun of the
city and how you know great it is like I
love these type of perfect storms
because when you see those fans
celebrating when you see those players
playing hard and really going at it it's
all those emotions in and so they're a
team that I'm going to be watching just
to see how it goes but more importantly
like to to kind of enjoy with the city
and everything just the fact that you
really can be hopeful no one knows who's
gonna win all that but you can
definitely be more hopeful than you can
be if you're Lions fan and that type of
stuff for me is fun to watch and can't
wait to see what Cleveland does this
yeah me too Chris but before that we'll
catch up talking about the the playoffs
have a great cast tonight thanks to the
call either man that's you go that's
Chris Webber for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
Direct TV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app